let's talk about this rasmussen thing
check this out yeah
so we have this poll from rasmussen
reports
do you agree or disagree with this
statement the media are truly the enemy
of the people agree
white people 56 black people 63 percent
other non-white 60 percent here this is
good look at this democrats 37
i got to be honest 37 of democrats
saying the media is the enemy of the
people
that's not bad i thought it would be
less than that unaffiliated 61 that's
those are the voters the gop needs the
gop is 76 but here's the biggest one
among all voters 58
of people think the media are the enemy
of the people now
i think insofar as it pertains to the
democratic voter
it probably includes peop you know us
and fox news and other channels to a
certain degree but let's be real when
people talk about the media
only ever when they were they're only
ever referring to us if they're
specifically addressing podcasts and
independent channels and things like
that
so i gotta say man you know curtis
you're somebody who who watches news all
day every day i think most people who
watch this show get it but i'm curious
your thoughts on why it is that the
majority of voters in this country at
least according to this poll think the
media
are truly the enemy of the people right
and
the overarching point on this is it's
all self-inflicted
entirely self-inflicted i don't i and
that's the biggest problem that i think
a lot of these corporate media
folks and organizations don't understand
and they refuse to acknowledge and if
they do they're continuing to lie which
is they think that somehow we are
responsible independent media
non-profits
conservatives you know just people that
aren't part of their borg for lack of a
better term org yeah i'm part of the
borg for lack of a better term but
and they've made so many mistakes over
the years and they're constantly saying
that if they make a mistake we always
correct it
no no you didn't i mean how do you make
up for thousands of minutes which we
catalogued on abc cbs and nbc looking at
the russia investigation
remember when cuomo pretended to be in
quarantine yeah cuomo pretending to be
in quarantine i mean you can look at big
examples you can look at small examples
and uh you go back to the bigger more
prominent ones of dan rather in 2004
making up things about george w bush's
national guard service you can look at
jason blair
making up stories about you know the dc
sniper case
and that and that doesn't even have to
do with like a
regular political story it's just
journalism gone wrong people making
things up uh fried zakaria he's a cnn
host he's been caught multiple times
plagiarizing wow it doesn't matter brian
williams obviously oh yeah is another
example so again this goes to this point
of a refusal to acknowledge that
the reason people think you are the
enemy of the people is because
of your own behavior and and then the
other last point is just a complete
detachment from
what you're covering and how it's not
what the people are looking for
so the scenes together and it and i
think in this all the points i've just
made goes to the fact of whether you
agree with the term or not i think no
matter what you think you should be you
should be able to accept the fact that
people feel this way um and that the
reasons for it are totally valid i i've
long thought you know how much easier
would life be if i just made a minecraft
channel
no i'm and i'm and i'm only somewhat
joking because i tell people look
success comes from hard work and drive
passion and there's a combination of
other things you know your abilities
you need some natural talent but for the
most part i think hard work can bring
perseverance bring success and i'm just
like if i allocated 16 hours a day into
minecraft videos or whatever video game
you know we probably doing way better
but upon hearing this i'm just like man
if if we on this show really were what
the media tried to smear us as grifters
just pandering to an audience we could
be making so much money if we went full
maga or full anti-trump if we just
played the dirty games and made up fake
news like cnn does we'd have all of the
best thumbnails i mean to be honest we
have the cast castle vlog right
and this is meant to be more comedic
it's meant to be silly it's not news
it's it's semi-fictional we had a bit
where the last time luke left the uh the
the castle he like the house blows up
like you know just as a gag
they're gags
but it's funny because when the videos
are
fictional when they're when they're
specifically jokes
people like clicking the more people
like being entertained so when you know
we're producing a show that's not news
you can just easily see you can just you
can just make up jokes that people will
click when it comes to news and we're
trying to be as honest and frame things
to the best of our abilities it's hard
to attract people with with
straightforward just like here's what
happened that's what i think cnn and
other media outlets figured out a long
long time ago everybody knows it
so these people who listen to cnn who
believe in these democrat voters and are
told by the likes of brian stelter that
you know fox news is the evil propaganda
and jake tapper saying don't read the
wikileaks emails you're not allowed
these are people who are
anybody who tells you not to read the
news or watch other channels is trying
to rip you off to make money off your
ratings that's what brian stelter did
and i think we should be and i should be
clear too that news busters a lot of us
on staff
look at all kinds of media sources not
just for a living but we want to know
what everyone is doing
we'll watch your show we will watch the
corporate meeting we will read the
physical newspapers and print
publications because we're old boomers
like
they're literally they're literally or
at heart you know but uh in just the
other week you had the president of nbc
saying that we're ferociously defending
the idea that it's possible to be
objective and nonpartisan our mission is
to illuminate and not advocate
what a joke that is yeah and and that's
the kind of high-mindedness and just
arrogance and i think that's the one of
the biggest thing another one of the
biggest things that people have problems
with
they have such arrogance uh you look at
the jake tappers of the world brian
uh joy reid nicole wallace rachel maddow
they have such
um you know hi they think so highly
themselves they love smelling their own
farts i mean that's that we're rapidly
approaching if not already there in that
territory with these people it's it's uh
it's pretty insidious and yet somehow
they continue to live in their bubbles
and
and yet they continue to be surprised
when things happen and people vote you
know for people other than their
candidates it's really weird that
they're in this bubble
and they've they've isolated themselves
and they're rejecting people from it
it's like
it kind of feels like they're trying to
get that last little drop of olive oil
from the olive you know everybody's
always like you got to get the extra
extra virgin olive oil that's when they
take the olive it's fresh and the oil
comes right out and then like the
regular stuff you get for the bargain
bin price is when it's a dried withered
husk and they're just squeezing whatever
they can that's what the media is
and the audience is that dried withered
husk but there are people who still
believe it you'd think after seven years
of russia
russia ah ian russia i was thinking
people would be like that's just it was
never true
wait if stelter came out and was like
ladies and gentlemen the sky over
ireland is red
it would you'd have hundreds of
thousands of people believe it just
because stelter said it well and then
the next day they'd come out and they'd
be like correction the sky was not red
but no one they wouldn't see it and
people would go on believing that the
sky was red over ireland they wouldn't
correct it some people might thought
like like the or whoever like um you
know the independent or like i don't
know random article like uh the hill
come out and be like uh correction that
did was not actually read stealth was
lying but they wouldn't see that stuff
they only watched shelter and yet what's
interesting is that's what they project
about people who don't follow them like
the conservatives libertarians uh that's
what they say chris matthews memorably i
recall when i would watch his show
before i had to watch joey reid's show
um
they replaced them um
he had this thing that said trump's
voters are the kind of people who if he
told them yes the sky isn't blue people
would believe them you know if they're
looking up movies to wat you know to go
see and they say
trump tells them the movie's at six and
it's actually at seven the people would
show up at six
you know i mean it was it's a classic
example projection when that's actually
how cnn viewers view themselves that
somehow they're still watching cnn and
all the rest of us have totally moved on
and they're just the good news is
they're continuing to shrink
but yet that small segment that's still
left continues to view us as
dangerous people like to your point
about joe rogan and sanchez gupta he
went in thinking he was about to get
attacked i i was perfectly fine i talked
to joe about that when i went on a show
and he was just like ah he was just
trying to be funny and i was like oh man
joe you're such a nice guy yeah i'm like
is he dude
isn't it kind of i'll say this you know
joe's trying to be a nice guy dro's i
think you know joe genuinely wants
people to kind of calm down and and and
work things through
but i'm like
isn't it kind of dangerous when a media
organization publishes a piece
in which they entertain the possibility
that joe would jump the table and
throttle someone's neck even if it's
supposed to be a joke like
sanjay gupta is not a comedian
you know so i have no problem with him
being funny and trying to make jokes i
have no problem you know people get mad
at me all the time because like i post
nonsense on twitter and then when
they're like people actually believe you
when you say this stuff you know and
i'll be like well that's their problem
like if you were a comedian i'd
understand and i'm like i don't care
dude
people can follow me so sanji could be
making a joke i totally get but the idea
that the joke exists signals that there
are people who genuinely fear this you
know fear joe and think him as some kind
of bad person
who would do something like that you
know what i mean yeah and i would
actually say something it's arguably far
more insidious that
i can i think i can say definitively
based on the people i know within the
industry that there are good people at
these networks that they know what
they're doing is wrong and that it's a
bit
you know
bill maher yeah and that barry weiss
thing
they know come on they've known the
whole time they're criticizing the the
lockdowns and everything now but there's
no way bill maher and barry weiss didn't
know what was going on you know what i
mean yeah that it would
the apoc the apocalyptic images even
that even if that
that should have done it for them
from the very beginning but what images
were just like the empty stores you know
empty streets you know just the idea of
that you know that people just life came
to a stop but but so so you know these
are these are public figures but imagine
the staff at you know at real time with
bill maher imagine the staff at cnn like
you were saying
like these these are people they know
what's going on the whole time they
don't speak out they don't speak up
yeah and and they know that
people who disagree with them are
capable of being good people the people
who are ideologically opposed to them
are their family members their neighbors
their spouses in some cases people that
they
go to church with
people that they went to high school or
college with and that's what really gets
me fired up that these people go on
television and they paint such a picture
that they almost want to gaslight these
people into thinking that
you know your friend your neighbor next
door who
doesn't vote straight d
is
some domestic terrorist
and i it's so wrong and yet joy reid and
all the rest continue to pile on and no
one says anything you don't see cnn
speaking up whenever something happens
on msnbc you don't really know you don't
really hear that it's just the
gentleman's agreement between all of
them they're not going to criticize each
other yeah it's funny too but you know
their key demo ratings are below 100k so
right so you know the relevance is i
have a yeah an interesting point to that
that brianna keeler uh had her role
they're rotating different people to
replace fredo cuomo at cnn
her show last week
through the first three days i looked at
nielsen's numbers
she lost two shows like my 600 pound
life
people puzzler on game show network
westerns such as gunsmoke
cheyenne
um
and you know are these like particularly
bad shows or something well no i've been
back on the website andy griffith show
you know really it spans the spectrum
really property brothers
uh the chip and joanna gaines channel uh
magnolia network yeah a number of shows
on there they got you were saying before
they got jim acosta on cnn right now is
that what it is yeah now it's jim acosta
and with brianna keeler they renamed the
9pm hour democracy in parole democracy
really what are you talking about like
there's so many other things going on in
the world and yet you're catering to the
small audience that you know whatever
john avalon who does this reality check
segment or mark elias wants right saying
this is such important work that every
american needs to turn it tune in you
think you think acosta is going to do
well in the ratings
uh well the first day no the first day's
numbers are in and he was the second
least watched show in all of cnn new day
which i was here six to nine a.m eastern
was the only show that acosta beat
wow in the day in the day the least of
all cnn shows of all cnn shows wow that
makes me feel pretty good honestly i was
i was worried i'm like he might actually
pull in the views because he's he's he's
like because he might get hate watch you
know hate watch and you know yeah i mean
great kelly with newsmax was two-thirds
of the way to jim acosta's viewership oh
man with news from newsmax didn't they
get pulled from like a bunch of
providers yeah yeah the la times report
has reported that that they weren't able
to withdraw i believe three different
cable providers and he still pulled in
over over 350 000 viewers last night
whereas acosta had
500 000 yeah but that was mostly old
people wasn't it well i mean once you
separate it out i mean that's true for a
lot of them once you split out the 25 to
54 demographic he's going to have like
70 000 in the key demo exactly and and
that's that's what is it 25 to 54 yeah
25 to 54.
that means most these people watching
are in their late in their late 50s
they're going to be they're going to be
aging out or 60 or 70 really many of
them will retire you know they'll still
vote for the next 15 20 years or
whatever um well i i guess my life
expectancy we're talking about 15 to 17
years yeah
and we're at a point now where last year
new day and brian stelter were losing
shows like peppa the pig
you know patrol i mean but come on paw
patrol's legit paw patrol is firefighter
dog yeah you can actually learn you
actually learn things on that show you
actually learn things moonshiners on
discovery channel
that's great
oh this says that cnn wants jim acosta
as the host of democracy in peril is
that right or were you saying brianna
keeler well she had last week in jim
acosta's on this week
democracy in peril that's real real bad
propaganda to put out to a country that
might be struggling right now and then
and of course yeah and they put uh i
believe the way the color scheme works
is blue
they put the democrats in democracy then
in is white and then
red is peril to be fair ian to be fair
ian we're just nobody's watching it's
white and blue baby let's sell some
tickets it's a bun you know it's a bunch
of older people who are i love that meme
the left is like fox news just scares
the elderly and i'm like maybe 20 or 30
years ago i don't know it's like that's
all cnn does right now if you watch
tucker what did you learn in the past
week that eminems aren't sexy anymore
bravo tucker that was a ridiculous
segment i think it was very dumb but
it's not scaring old people and tucker's
got massive youth uh key demo viewership
so tucker talks about a wide range of
things he challenges the establishment
my personal opinion is i think when it
comes to cable tv tucker's the best not
that i think he's perfect and i don't
think anybody is no but i'm not a fan of
like i'm you know i put it this way
across the board with all of the cable
tv stuff tucker is the only one who gets
like a c plus for me and everyone else
he had a jimmy dore on last time
and let jimmy just explode in a rage of
fire it was amazing and then at the end
he was like jimmy dore ladies and
gentlemen yeah yeah it was great jimmy
doing what jimmy does and that's why
and the people that calling for
censorship when you guys have my
colleague dan gainer on um
and why i always say things like
internet and the internet and social
media are net positive is because it
allows this proliferation of all these
different alternative forms of media
whereas before you had three networks
that had newscasts in the morning and in
the evening
and
they weren't even they went off air
overnight they didn't even have things
in prime time you know they really
didn't have capabilities to break in
when there would be big stories at night
or the middle of the afternoon
uh they really have the same amount of
resources whereas now you have all these
different options for all these niche
kinds of pop you know topics um and you
know advocating for all these different
positions and why would you want to get
rid of that yeah you're upset because
you're losing control
uh and if you're somebody like jeff
zucker
you know
you're not able to control america from
your little green room you know radio is
still really popular you know because
people drive their cars people have some
of the radio and you know you've got
satellite radio and people don't
understand it actually is fairly popular
uh you buy new cars these days a lot of
them come with satellite radio so
a lot of these older formats still exist
in some form and they still have some
kind of pull so we can sit here and we
can laugh about cnn's ratings being in
the gutter but i i got to be honest they
that youtube props them up youtube puts
them on the front page so we we can be
critical of them and say their medium is
dying but they will be put on life
support because
that brand has has some kind of value
you know when cnn launched what like the
mid 80s
initially it was just like what is this
fly by night you know stupid cable trip
but nowadays you've got you know i i was
born in 86 so i grew up with cnn always
being there and that that that matters
its legacy now to to the younger
generations no matter what happens to
their ratings someone's going to want
that and they'll try and put it wherever
they can but i do think cnn like many
companies will eventually just you know
aol used to be the big game in media or
i'm sorry an internet now it's gone
facebook could potentially you know go
that route we don't know a lot of
companies that have been around since
they're lining in hundreds change their
name and they continue to exist cnn is
owned by a t so we might as well just
call cnn a t from now on well and
they're about to be spun off to
discovery um
cnn's getting sold to discovery yes at t
is trying to they're offloading cnn oh
yeah and they've been trying to offload
direct tv look to offload them as well
so
uh and that's what's really interesting
that i'm really some people are holding
out hope for in 2022 when discovery more
or less takes over if they're going to
clean house one of their lead investors
i think even somebody on their board was
on cnbc
a couple months ago and suggested that
we need to get cnn back to the cnn that
people were called that they had fond
memories of growing up you know i guess
so primarily like gulf war age people
that were watching cnn the early 90s
with the 80s
a little bit after it launched once
people realized what it actually is
um
but at that point you got a really clean
house if you want to do that the
challenge is that straight news dime a
dozen
we've got so many people on the ground
with cell phones filming and
broadcasting that when it comes to
straight reporting it's it's fairly easy
to get now there there are some things
that we've seen at timcast.com
that are underserved certain areas so um
march coverage protest and political
action stuff often is is extremely
under-reported so you might get a
reporter from a local news outlet will
show up film a few segments and then put
like a 30-second package together it
doesn't really give you the the you know
the actual view of what's going on and
that's something i you know got started
doing so we try to do that we try to say
let's get someone on there let's do like
a 20 to 30 minute actually talking to
people and figure out if we can get a
broad view of things but for the most
part it's very very difficult to
monetize it's very very difficult to
provide a service in an area where it's
just saturated with citizen journalism
so you can see it cnn tries to do
documentary they try to be like vice
they get reza oslon you know he ate
human brain
you're aware of that right yes and that
was uh desperation that was desperation
and spoiler alert it didn't work out for
him that cnn one of the few times
they've actually got rid of someone
that was
that was when cnn ran a show where a
human ate another human's brain and then
that was a small piece that was too far
for them that that we finally found out
where's the line for cnn yeah seriously
that's crazy they were like you know i
can only imagine the executives are like
human eating human brain didn't work for
us maybe we can accuse the president of
being a russian spy for for five years
seven years yeah kind of working just
wrong with it just right yeah
yeah that one's uh technically it's
based in the realm of possibility like
you know sure the russians exist and
true yes trump exists and trump exists
and he calls somebody once yeah yeah in
russia they can just make up everything
and roll with it and never correct just
mad libs at this point you know
mad libs do you love people yeah
and i think and i think that's why
people really dislike cnn in particular
and the broadcast networks versus say
msnbc or even fox news
because cnn passes itself off as
you know based on nostalgia they're
they're hoping people continue to
support them based on nostalgia and
basic news of the who what where when
why and how
um
proper context and perspective that's
what they're hoping people you know fall
for but you very quickly see
even just on their chirons alone so you
don't even have to have the sound on to
know that it's a total joke and so
i would say i'm more likely to be able
to stomach msnbc than i am cnn just
because
you know what they're getting they're
not trying to hide what they are
and you know you just go from there
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you